here
Well, good morning again Church. My name is John and I get the
privilege to service Lee teaching Pastor here. If you are new, I'd love to meet you.
Just come say hi after I love doing that connecting with
you. We are finishing up a short Series today on
the spiritual disciplines those habits in our
lives that increase our love for Jesus and also make
us more like Jesus. That's the point not just to have
something we do regularly on our calendar but to make us
like him and today we're talking about giving
It's been said that if you want to know what someone really values check
two things their calendar and their
bank account.
You can see what someone values by those two
things which is one reason many people get uncomfortable when
we talk about money in the church because it
affects us to the deepest parts of
who we are it touches those core decisions and
motivations.
It's also why we protect ourselves and and self-justify while
we avoid to give.
But here's what I hope as we study what God says here
about giving what what makes us more
like Jesus as we give what I hope you see today is
that giving is one evidence that God's grace is
at work in your heart.
That's the the hope I have that you walk away with that
is it giving is one evidence?
That God's grace is at work in your heart.
Now if you're here and you don't believe in Jesus yet first, let me
say thank you for being here. Keep coming back keep asking questions.
But this sermon is primarily for believers.
Those who have received the grace of God in
our hearts that it can be working in us. So
just listen. I hope you see Jesus in all of this today, of
course, but but realize let's think about that as we
think through this. This is for us who are believers.
And so if you're not already there take your copy of God's word and turn
with me to Second Corinthians.
Ryan preached so well last week from First Corinthians. This
is the next letter Paul wrote to this
church in Corinth.
Now every time we read God's word are we study it? We need to understand it's context.
So as you're turning there, let me give you a little bit background here
because we need to know what's going on. Help us understand how we are to
read this especially in this these two chapters of
chapters 8 and 9 of 2nd Corinthians. What was happening behind
the scenes that leads us to now what we're
reading.
So what was happening was on the Apostle Paul's third missionary journey,
which we saw when we went through acts last year. We were watching him
take these long Journeys around the Mediterranean.
On his third Journey one of his tasks was
to collect a relief offering for the impoverished Christians back
around Jerusalem where they had originally started, of
course the church there and they're sending missionaries all over there were
still some left and they were impoverished because they were
being persecuted for their faith. They were
being kicked out of their family in many cases losing jobs. They were
really feeling cast out of society in
some ways. And so Paul was concerned to meet
their physical needs. Yes, but also he had an ulterior
motive in this relief offering
As I said, they'd sent missionaries to plant churches all
over the Gentile world the non-jewish background World. Well
Paul wanted to strengthen the unity between
the Gentile background Believers and the Jewish background Believers. He
wanted to tie those to together. So this
offering was part of that.
Here's the problem. He's addressing in Corinthians, though.
the Corinthian Church
We're not doing their part.
In giving what they'd promised to give.
A year earlier they had said we're going to do this. We're going to give and
they just hadn't done it yet. So he's writing this part of
this letter to them for that reason.
What he does, is he elevates his appeal to the highest
spiritual level possible.
He says here in synchronization nine that that giving is
an act of Grace.
Giving is actually an act of Grace. He used a few different words throughout to
refer to this offering he's talking about and the most he
used was the word grace for the offering.
This is Grace to give like this.
That's why I said giving us one evidence that God's grace is at work in your heart.
That the Lord has so transformed you.
that you can't help but give
and you can't help but give that's what this passage
will show us.
What it looks like for your giving to be motivated by God's grace.
That's what we want. It's not just because somebody told you
to because you feel like you're supposed to it's because it's motivated From
the Inside Out by God's grace.
So how do we know it is? What are some signs? We know giving us
motivated by Grace first. It's when you give in spite of circumstances.
We know it's motivated by God's grace when you give
in spite of circumstances.
This is chapter 8 look at verses 1 through 4
to start with we're just going to work through the whole Passage.
It says we want you to know brothers. That's the church in Corinth about
the grace of God that's been among the churches of Macedonia.
That's a whole different area of the world.
For in a severe test of Affliction their Abundance
of Joy, they're extreme poverty have overflowed in
a wealth of generosity on their part.
For they gave according to their means as I can testify and beyond their
means of their own accord begging us earnestly for
the favor of taking part in the relief of the
Saints.
So notice what Paul's doing here?
Again, he wants to motivate the Corinthian Church to
give.
And he referenced the churches in Macedonia.
And those churches in Macedonia had given in a
severe test of affliction.
What was that test? Well, it was that they were experiencing extreme poverty.
Like they had hit rock bottom. They had very little
of anything and they had very little hope of getting anything.
They were as poor as you can get.
But did that hinder them from giving?
No.
This is in fact, they gave joyfully they gave abundantly they
gave what they could and they gave plus some they gave
beyond their means.
Why?
verse 1
because of the grace of God that had been given to them.
It was the grace of God that was leading them
to even beg. It says for the
favor the grace.
Of getting to take part in this offering. How often do you see people begging
to give right?
These people are saying we want to give I know we're poor but we want to give and
they weren't giving out a guilt. They weren't giving out of pressure their
desire to give was because of God's grace inside of
them.
so changing their heart that they couldn't help but want to give
Listen, we will rarely look at our circumstances and
see the inspiration to
give.
Right. There's always going to be more bills coming. There's always
going to be future plans. There's the numbers won't add up.
There's you just lost a job or medical bill comes
in like there's always going to be that but when you have experienced the
matchless grace of God,
in your life
Then difficult times. Stop being an excuse not
to give
When you give according to God's grace
not in your circumstances, that doesn't
affect it. That's when you know God's grace is at work in your heart.
Second we know you're giving is motivated by God's grace when you give excellently.
As we continue through his letter here when you give
excellently. We see that's by God's grace. It's motivating
you.
This is verses 5 through 7.
Talking still about the Macedonian Church. He says this not
as we expected but they gave themselves first to
the Lord then by the will of God to us.
Accordingly we urged Titus that as he had started so he
should complete among you this act of Grace.
But as you excel in everything in faith
and speech and knowledge in all earnestness in
our love for you see that you excel in
this act of Grace also.
Saw that word excel a couple times right that word means abundant or excessive
or more than enough.
and so Paul wrote this to them saying not only
are you two go above and beyond in your Holiness in
your life in the way you speak the way you act the way you love
one another not only go above and beyond that way excel
in this act of Grace called giving
excel in giving as well over
the top abundantly.
But again notice, let's tie it back what it said earlier.
This pursuit of Excellence is grounded in verse 5 where
it says they gave themselves first to the
Lord and then by the will of God to us.
That they're giving was a response to God's
grace that they were responding to the gospel first,
and then they gave to everyone else around them.
So at First Corinthians 10:31 says
whether you eat or drink, whatever you do do all to the
glory of God.
Even giving must be first to him.
and then to others
because here's the reality.
He's saying this to them that if they have already given
them their whole selves to God.
If they've already given their whole selves to God, it's not hard
to give stuff or money or time to God so
that he receives more Glory.
It's already all his.
And so I'm gonna give it away.
But that's where excellent giving comes from.
That yes others receive benefits when we give but ultimately
we are giving to the Lord first we are doing it
for him first. And so when you think about it that way do we
really want to do that half-heartedly?
If we're giving to him, we want to kind of
Half Baked that right and just don't do it all in right?
We're giving to the Lord first. That means we will do it. Excellently.
We see an example of that.
from Jesus himself
The whole point of spiritual disciplines is to become more like Jesus, right? We see
an example of his kind of giving right here that
that our giving is driven by God's grace when we give as
Jesus gave
we start to see how he gave to us when we
start to give away like he did then it starts
to show up as motivated by grace.
Continuing chapter 8 look at verse 8.
I say this not as a command, but to prove by the earnestness of
others that your love also is genuine. Meaning
that the love of God is inside you that
giving is an illustration what he's already done inside you.
You're proving it by your generosity.
verse 9 for you know the grace of our Lord Jesus Christ
that though he was rich yet for your sake he
became poor so that you buy his poverty might become rich
All this is doing is pointing us back to the gospel again, right?
You see how this all comes back to Grace.
It points us to Philippians 2, which says that
that though he was in the form of God. He did
not count equality with God a thing to be grasped or held on
to but he emptied himself taking on form of a servant
born in the likeness of men being found in human form.
He humbled himself further by becoming obedient to the point of death even
death on a cross.
Did you see what happened Jesus gave sacrificially? No strings
attached. He said I am going to give everything for
you. Why?
Because he loves us.
Because he wants to give good gifts to his children.
Because he wants to make us rich in his family.
By adopting Us in right?
Now listen that inheritance he's talking about right there has nothing to
do with with financial wealth.
It has everything to do with spiritual wealth.
Right. That's what he's talking about here that Jesus Took on
our sin poverty in a sense.
So that those who repent and believe in him could
receive the wealth of his righteousness.
It's a spiritual transaction a spiritual inheritance that we have the
ability now where we couldn't before now we
can stand before God completely perfect forever and
ever.
We were poor now. We're rich in him.
That's our example now.
Jesus gave sacrificially for
us spiritually
that his life death and Resurrection completely given
everything away setting aside all of that giving it
away here because he gave
we are to give sacrificially for others as well.
With everything we are time Talent resources
all of that. Yes, including financially.
Because he's writing second Corinthians 8 and 9
in the context of a financial gift.
So he's saying this is part of the deal we are to
give to each other.
Give to the Lord first and to each other financially.
We give as Jesus gave.
There's another evidence we find here God's grace
transforming your heart.
when you give willingly
it's how you know God's motivating it.
back in second Corinthians 8 look at verses 10
through 12
He says in this matter, I give my judgment this benefits
you who a year ago started not only to do this work, but
also to desire to do it.
So now finished doing it as well. So your Readiness
and Desiring it maybe matched by your completing it out of what you have.
For if the Readiness is there it's acceptable according to what a person has
not according to what he does not have.
So there's a couple aspects of this first notice that this
kind of giving he's talking about here. As I said with willingly. It
must not be and cannot truly
be coerced.
He's talking about giving that is desired you're ready
for it. Right? Those words are not coerced words.
Those are willing words.
In other words, you should not give just because somebody stood up
here and guilt tripped you.
It's not coerced. It's not pulled out of you. This
is a willing desire. But also catch this part
of it. It must not just be willingness.
There must also be a doing-ness. It's not
even a word. I don't know but it's like you see what I mean.
Willingness must be matched by a
follow through doing it.
Can't just want to you actually need to do
it.
Now I want to clarify something at this point and I
love how verse 12 actually did it already for me. So we're
going to look at it again.
See some people hear all of this.
When they hear somebody stand up in church and start talking about money. We're here
sermon on like this read through segregate and we start
to think
You can start to think that if I don't give a lot
of money, it doesn't count.
So what you're telling me is I got to give a whole lot for God
to notice.
Look at how verse 12 says it though.
He says it's according to what you have not
what you don't have.
He's not judging you on some standard of somebody else or comparing it
anybody else. It's it's what you have you are to give according to
what God has entrusted to you right now.
Not even what you had before what you will have in the future. What do
you have right now? This is the illustration Jesus
gave about the Widow in Luke 21.
Remember that story?
Jesus in the temple, he's watching people come and give
and he notices this Widow and he tells this this is Luke 21.
This Widow who?
in that Society
know that was was pretty hopeless.
A widow who might have had no
income might have been a beggar at times a widow who
was cast out a society in many cases. This
is the the scene that he's watching in the temple that Jesus
looked up and he saw the rich putting their gifts into the offering box.
And he saw a poor Widow put in two small copper coins
like pennies.
And Jesus said truly I tell you this poor Widow
has put in more than all of them.
For they all contributed out of their abundance meaning
just whatever they had left over extra all the money
that they made but she out of her poverty put
in all she had to live on.
What a step of Faith, right?
It's an illustration of what it's been said elsewhere that God sees
not the portion but the proportion.
in other words he's seeing
your heart
whether you have a lot whether you give a lot or whether you have a little and you
give a little comparatively he sees your heart.
And that's a scary thought because God then just think about that
God knows if you could have given more and you didn't.
But also the encouragement here the encouragement in that too.
that God knows if you wanted to give more but
you couldn't
just right now this medical bill came in
and we just can't make it right now. We're literally not going to put food
on the table. And yeah, I want to give God I want
to give more I want to do this.
That's why when we're talking about Grace giving we're not talking about a certain
minimum percentage.
And it's like a bill that just comes out of your checking account
every and you just got this money going out and that's all it is. You like you're
checking another box. That's not what we're talking about here. We're talking about God stirring
Your Heart by his grace like
in Exodus 35 and 36 when the Israelites were
Furnishing the Tabernacle God stirs their
heart to where they just start giving a whole lot and they
just say well I got this i got this let me provide for this and they start bringing so
much that God says to hold up. You got to stop giving your two you're
giving too much.
What a crazy cool thing. That would be right. You guys need
to stop giving we have too much.
That's the point here Grace giving.
When you start to give willingly you start to give out of the abundance
of your heart and the grace he's given to you. That's when you know God
is at work.
It's not forced. It's not guilt.
It's just because you love God so much.
there's one more way we see in chapter 8 we know God's grace is
at work in our giving
It's when we give by faith.
Back in 28 when we give by faith.
Paul efforts actually references The Exodus again here in verses
13 through 15.
He says I do not mean that others should be eased and you burdened but
that is a matter of fairness your abundance of the present time
should Supply their needs. So they're abundance May Supply your need.
That there may be fairness as it is written. Whoever gathered
much had nothing left over and whoever gathered little
Had No Lack
So what he's talking about there that last verse he's referencing the
Israelites in the wilderness.
Where if you don't know that story every day?
They don't have the ability to provide themselves food. And so every day they'd
walk out of their tents. And God would have laid this
Dew on the ground.
And it was bread.
And so naturally right they walk out. They're like, what is that? Nobody? I
don't know what that is. So they called it Mana which means I don't know so they
they walk out and God calls them day by
day to walk out collect enough for their family and go
back in and they have provided for them the food they
need.
But here's the thing if they tried to store it up.
for the next day
it would spoil.
now
there was one day it didn't that was on the day
before the Sabbath they would collect for two days and it wouldn't spool because God didn't
want them to go work on the Sabbath day. He commanded it that
way and it didn't spoil every other day. It's spoiled.
And so that person had that family had to trust that
they'd wake up that morning walk out of the tent and there'd be
enough out there and they'd go collect it and they'd go eat and
they'd have it and then the next day they'd have to trust again go
out the tent and like God I'm believing. It's out there and you
go outside and you eat and you come in.
But I don't trust you today. So I'm gonna hold I'm gonna hold
it. I'm gonna Store It Up.
He's like that's not what you do.
And it goes bad.
What happened was God was teaching them
how to trust him every day?
how to have faith that he would provide
it's the same for these Corinthian believers.
These Gentile believers who were supposed to
help the Jewish Believers financially, right? They had to
give by faith because they weren't Rich they had to give by faith as
well. And so they're giving like am I going to have enough for tomorrow?
What about next week? I don't know how my income level is
coming. Am I going to have enough?
The principle is what Jesus said in Matthew 6 when we give by faith.
Our Heavenly Father Knows What You
Need?
All these things all your daily needs he knows that
but he says seek first the kingdom of God and his righteousness
and all these things will be added to you. Your daily
needs will be provided as you seek first and you give you obey he
will provide for you.
See that again later.
So that's chapter 8 that's the idea of how
how we are to give with the right heart
the right Spirit. That's what it looks like. Those are the markers of
it. But what Paul then does in verses 16 through
24.
Is he moves into like a logistics section? It
kind of takes a bit of an aside and he's talking about how this offering
is supposed to be delivered and handled as the Corinthians would
take it in and how it got back to Jerusalem, and he
especially talks about the trustworthiness of those who are
handling the money.
So as I was reading this I was thinking about us as leaders
that we're constantly reexamining and reflecting on what
we've been entrusted with the heavy responsibility of
handling and stewarding God's resources
as a church.
To direct it in the right way and to say God. What do
you want to do with this? And we believe clearly that
God has called us to these certain things to
glorify him by becoming a hub for an all ages disciple making
Movement. We believe that's where God wants to to lead
us and so we we do that we move in directions
as we go that way which we believe leads to
lives transformed.
here in Edmond
Network churches plan like you heard about Brett and all of
that already that's an evidence that God is at work.
We want to have the resources directed towards things like that.
Church has planted like Santa Cruz and Saint Louis and everyday
missionary sent to the ends of the world. Like we've seen in the
last few weeks over and over again people commissioned to go. We want God
to use us towards those ends. And
so we have the responsibility to Steward his resources towards
that
and so we focus our efforts on equipping each other to love
Jesus and live sin. That's the daily task. We have as
a church that we're stewarding towards.
We have that responsibility.
and this passage reflects that
we feel the weight of that as Leaders even with the money
that God entrusts to our church. We are
called to be generous and sacrificial as well.
But once he'd explained that what he does
then is in chapter 9 as he picks back up with the
grace giving theme.
And he shows how that giving would play out. What
are its results in the world in those lives when
you give all the ways we've seen what is your giving actually do?
Well first it will prompt others you're giving
will actually prompt others to give
as well. Look at this chapter 9 now.
verses 1 through 5
It is Superfluous to write to the you about the ministry of this
for the Saints for I know you're Readiness of which I boast about you to the
people of Macedonia saying that okay or Corinth has been ready
since last year your Zeal stirred up most of them.
But I'm sending the brothers so that our boasting about you may not prove empty in
this matter. So you may be ready as I said you would be otherwise if
some macedonians come with me find you're not
ready. We'd be humiliated to say nothing of you for being so
confident.
So I thought it necessary to urge the brothers to go on ahead
and arrange in advance for the gift you've promised. So maybe ready as
a willing gift not as an exaction.
And so notice what he's doing here remember a year earlier he'd used
the zealous Readiness of the Corinthians to motivate the
macedonians now, he's saying hey
Corinthians listen to the macedonians how watch how
they gave so readily you guys need to do it, too.
He flipped it.
And they're motivating each other and they're prompted by
one generosity so they would be generous as
well.
He didn't want them to be embarrassed by saying man. They didn't follow
through on their commitment.
They needed to be not just willing but actually do it.
But here's the thing about that.
when you think about what Jesus said Matthew 6 about
secret giving we should not let her right hand know. What a left hand is doing. How
does that square with this that we're trying to motivate people to give without broadcasting
what we give?
Like I don't know how much any of you give like so so what
what do we how do we motivate each other to give without saying
here so much. I've given well remember he's talking to a
church here.
He's saying complete the commitment you made and what
would happen is people transformed by the grace of God in their hearts. They're
going to step forward to be willing.
Doesn't mean they're better. Nobody even knows what they're giving. It's just they're
going to do it and motivate others to do it as
they lead out in giving.
That's the idea here of what it is. We don't know what each other
would give necessarily but it's motivating and prompting
others as we show a step of Faith other people
will follow along.
That's what he did with Corinth and Macedonia here.
So it'll prompt others another result.
When you give with the right heart, it will also bless you.
It'll prompt others.
But it will bless you as well.
Now this can't be the primary motivation because that would be just selfish
right? I'm gonna give so I get right and that's
not the point.
But it is a nice fringe benefits. We'll see here in verses 6 through
11 of chapter 9.
The point is this whoever so sparingly will also reap sparingly.
Whoever sows bountifully will
also reap bountifully.
Each one must give us he has decided in his heart not
reluctantly or under compulsion for God loves a
cheerful Giver. The word actually Greek is
hilarious Giver.
And God is able to make all grace abound to you so that having
all sufficiency in all things at all times. You
may abound in every good work comprehensive.
As it is written. He's distributed freely. He's given to the poor his righteousness
endures forever.
He who supplies seed to the sower and bread for food
will supply and multiply your seed for sowing increase
the Harvest of your righteousness. You will be enriched in
every way to be generous in every way which through us will
produce Thanksgiving to God.
Now I did grow up in Northwest, Oklahoma.
But I am about the furthest thing from a farmer you'll ever find in life.
Well, my buddies were out driving tractors in combines. I was sitting
in an air conditioned snow cone hut that I owned that I was eating snow cones
all day. So trade off. I'll take that
one, right?
But I do know.
basic logic about harvesting
This tells us that in harvesting wheat?
The more seed you put in the ground.
The more grain you have the potential of reaping.
Right, it makes sense.
There's more fruit that you could enjoy as God
works.
It makes total sense, right?
The more God will give you as this says more. God
will give you in order to bless other people with it.
And I hope you caught that.
As you're reading this.
I hope you caught that because there are false teachers out there who will
tell you that the more seed you put in means you will
then reap wealth and health rewards
on the back side of it.
That you will reap a reward
that will make your life comfortable and all of
those things will come because you give more because you put more seed in the
ground. That's what is often said.
Now, I'm not good. God does give us good things to
enjoy he gives us his provision for
us to enjoy and use absolutely but
all over this passage.
Did you see it? The more God is giving
you is for more Ministry.
Did you see that right verse 8?
You abound yes in order to abound in
more good works.
It's giving
verse 10. He multiplies seed for more sowing.
Verse 11 you are enriched to be generous. You
see it here.
God blesses us to be a blessing to
others.
Not to hoard not to accumulate not to
selfishly seek our own Comfort all the time but to
give more.
Let me just think about as Jesus said it's better to
give than to receive.
That's true.
What a blessing it is for you to be able to bless other
people and meet needs and care for them. It's such
a gift to your soul a blessing
to you to give away.
It's so encouraging.
In fact, that's what Paul comes back to and next in verse 12. He
says when you give it will actually meet needs and other
people.
Like verse 12 look at it.
For the ministry of this service, which is a word about
the temple and sacrifices. We'll get to in a second. The ministry
of this service is not only supplying the needs of the Saints,
but it's also overflowing in many Thanksgiving to God.
Right. So he's saying this is a spiritual service like the priests and
the temple brought sacrifices to the Lord. This is
this same thing. We're giving it to the Lord first. This
is a sacrifice a gift to him, but
then it helps other people along the way.
It cares for that's how God cares for his body.
Because God doesn't need your money.
Right God owns everything.
He doesn't need the money. He gives you
the money so you can provide for his body.
That's what Hebrews 13 says don't neglect to do
good and share with others for with such sacrifices. God
is pleased you have
the ability to help people all around you
to be generous with your money time Talent
X all of that resources, and you can just give and
give and give nobody has to know you don't give through the
church you get all kinds of different places as God has blessed you.
But also want to let you know about something that we have at the church.
As you give yourself but there's also a thing called benevolence fund
here at the church.
It's overseen by the deacons people give to it regularly people
give to it one time.
What it is is a fund
designated to help members of our church in
times of need.
That they need some financial hardship some help to overcome
that or they hit a really hard season of life and they just
need a little bit of help along. That's what that's for.
It's a way for us to gather to care for the
body.
You can individually you can't as Community groups of course,
but this is a church-wide thing the more we do together the more we can
see God do so. That's where we have What's called the
benevolence fund?
It's God meeting needs through his
body.
But again what that results in the end
of 12 said it you're giving will glorify God.
When you give and people's needs are met when you
give in these ways. God is glorified.
verse 13 continues it
By their approval of this service, they will glorify God
because of your submission to come from the confession the gospel the generosity
of your contribution for them and for all the others.
Like when you give do you hear that when you
give you reflect the gospel?
You give like Jesus gave like we saw Earth. This is what
it does. It shows you've been changed and
it points people to The Giver of all of those good gifts. It
points people to God himself and he gets the glory for it.
See that's that's our hope as as leaders in
the church. Our hope is that people in the world around us see
us as a church.
They see us not only preaching the gospel, but
also living in light of the Gospel.
That we're not hoarding. We're not about our own Comforts. We're
about tangibly helping people in need all around
us the ways that we can and I know when we
talk talking about like giving money and resources away that that
that's not preaching the gospel. I know that
but often the way we give to people opens
up conversations opens up
their hearts to where they finally listen where they were hard before
where they now know we care for them. So they
might listen to what we're saying now.
We're not all about ourselves. We're about others. It
doesn't have to be in either or we can both preach
the gospel proclaim the gospel and glorify
God in that and give in response to
the Lord's work in US practically obeying the
gospel and glorifying God in that too. We can
do both
so we can give even more as a
church.
away
But there's one more tangible benefit.
God's people giving according to God's grace.
It's that it will unite God's people.
When you give like we've seen in chapter
8 it will Unite.
God's people
because remember that was the whole point. Paul was writing this letter.
The whole point of this section is that the Gentiles and
Corinth he wanted them to feel more connected to the Jewish Believers and Israel.
He wanted them to feel more connected to the Gentile Believers over there.
He wanted it all because when they gave out of love what
verse 14 says is that they they will long
for you. They will pray for you because of the
surpassing grace of God upon you.
When they gave the Jewish background Believers Started
Loving them more and that Unity came together.
I remember sitting in an old church building in
Whitley Bay, England.
Which is near Newcastle up on the Northeast Coast.
And there were just a few church members left who live in a very
dark area spiritually.
And I was hearing them say how thankful they
were for our little Church in Fort Worth that
they were praying for us.
Why were they saying that?
Because we had generously invested time.
And resources and ideas and people and money
to advance God's Mission
there in that area.
And listen that was not a church growth strategy for us in Fort
Worth.
We would read no benefit of anybody coming to our church
because of that. It was a big sea church growth
mentality. It was a kingdom Advance mentality all the
way on the other side of the world.
And we were saying we're in we want to invest in that Kingdom work
and that knit our hearts together from thousands
of miles away many people in our church never even met those
people in for in in Whitley Bay, but they
were one body together.
But again, let's go back to the start.
Where does that kind of desire to give come from?
Like where does that kind of desire to invest where does
that come from?
Well, look at verse 15 it closes what
he started with right? He says thanks be to
God for his inexpressible gift.
What's the gift?
It's the gospel the grace of
God. Thanks be to God inexpressible the desire to give
comes from the gospel.
See when you and I are so deeply impacted by
God's grace in us when we realize and
recall what he has given to us
in forgiveness through his life death and resurrection that
we were poverty.
sin poverty now, he's given us righteousness wealth
all of that when we remember where
we've come from like we saying before
That can't help but humble us onto our
knees with the desire to bless others like we've been
blessed.
Giving comes from the gospel. It's what second Corinthians
5 says the love of Christ controls us.
that those who live might no longer live for themselves, but for
his sake
he died for us.
So what else can we do but say I'm gonna live for you.
He died. He was raised. It's changed my life. I'm living
for you. And the gospel is what leads us
to reimagine what generosity looks like in our
lives.
That we now can use the money God's
entrusted to us. But also the time the
skill the effort the resources all those things we can use that
for his kingdom purposes. However, he's saying I
want to do
because remember
You don't own any of that?
You don't own your body. You don't own your history. You don't own the money. You have the
the house the family. You don't own any of that. You
didn't manufacture any of that. It's God's grace to
you. So you're a steward not an owner.
And as a steward, it totally changes the way you live
your life.
And you can say Okay God.
This is yours. How do you want me to use it?
Because of his grace he's given it to you now you Steward it?
So before we go any further, I want to just examine.
Where we each are in this process in this
area?
Ask you a bold question if you're not giving at
all.
Why not?
Maybe you've never seen the grace of God like this.
Well, let me just challenge. You take a step baby step
even.
And just start.
Just start giving an investing in God's Kingdom.
In your life day by day through the church as well.
Just start investing in God's kingdom work.
Or maybe you give here and there when you have a little bit extra and you make sure you cover
everything's covered. And then whatever's left over there's usually more month than
Finance at the end of this right nice. Somehow. We
just let that slide start to give consistently.
Give first give consistently to the Lord before everything
else and then see what he stretches out the
rest of that money to fit.
Or maybe you have been giving consistently and today maybe
you see.
It's a time for me to invest in bigger ways in
God's Kingdom.
Things around the world things through the church and you sound I want to
be investing more.
Seeing all of this for his glory. So that's one
side of it consider where we are financially how we're doing that but
here's the other side.
we also
need to think about our daily lives and our attitudes towards
money.
Are you greedy?
You wasteful.
Are you focusing on temporary Pleasures rather
than Eternal priorities in any way?
And so what we need to do then with all of that as we consider.
What that teaches the world around us about what we value what that
teaches our own children what we value in life and how we use that we
need to lay that all before the Lord and just say to
him God. I want to submit all of this to
your to your will.
You are the king of everything. You're in charge. You're
the owner. This is yours and you just lay it in submission
before him hold it open handed and you
make adjustments to follow him in the
way you need to and then let me let me remind you
that's going to bring blessing in your
life.
Maybe not in the way that somebody will think you would be blessed or
the way you want to be blessed but you will be a part of God's work
that you may never have been before.
And you'll see God do things that you can't take
the credit for that's bigger than you you can invest in
God's kingdom work.
let's lay it there submit to him as the king
as the gracious savior of your life and say
God this is yours do with it what you will
it's worth it Church.
It is worth it.
Why?
Because Jesus is worth it.